i was just scrolling through twitter
were you aware of the amount of love
that
that eddie
has there's two main reactions that i'm
seeing heartbroken and rage at the
dumpers
yeah i got a text from the doctors a
couple of weeks ago i was saying kind of
we're bracing ourselves what are you
even looking for madonna blondie bowie
beetles music we need music
it's kind of it's a completely
overwhelming feeling it's so lovely like
the the devotion that the fans have for
this show and kind of how they've found
space in their heart for the for a new
character it's heartwarming but i don't
even know what to say about it it's
really they've been so gracious and
welcoming it's
lovely
this is funny
[Music]
so let's get into it specifically when
did the brothers tell you that eddie
goes out as a hero uh well they didn't
kind of tell me specifically they kind
of texted me during the hiatus being
like can you play guitar i said yes
question mark nothing
and then and then they just kind of
dropped the last three scripts into my
inbox and kind of i read it and then
didn't really talk to them until we kind
of went back to film
um
and i was just are you kidding i just
think
i think there's very few worlds in which
and what i think it might be the only
world where like a sequence like that
kind of
can exist and it not feel ridiculous i
mean obviously it is ridiculous but it's
it feels earned and it feels fun and it
feels like the perfect crescendo for
this kind of this crazy sequence and
um yeah i just think that the
inventiveness to kind of come up with
that and
the bravery to put it in of it's um yeah
well done duffer brothers so how much of
how much of that is you playing master
of puppets it's an awesome moment
it's pretty much all of me yeah i'm i
kind of we we got this kind of black
belt uh kind of uh metal guitarist to
play the solo because um that just
wasn't gonna happen
but
then but i was lucky that i kind of i
played guitar since i was quite young so
i had kind of the foundations that kind
of
take take most of it
um but yeah it's great fun you know who
wouldn't want to kind of be a rock star
for an afternoon yeah yeah once you saw
the final episode what was your reaction
to
watching dustin talk to eddie's uncle
and having that moment of closure for
eddie's uncle
i wish everyone had gotten to know him
really know him
because they would have loved him
mr munson
they would have loved him
even in the end
he never stopped being eddie
despite
everything
oh it's so beautiful isn't it um i think
that they both
did that scene so delicately and yeah
gorgeous is so gorgeous and i think kind
of the main injustice
that i think people are kind of the pill
that people are kind of finding hard to
swallow is the fact that he's he he
people don't know that he dies a hero
it's quite the opposite you know he dies
um a villain
um and i think kind of the the
tenderness in the in the fact that kind
of the uncle
um
yeah eddie's uncle knows that um
he wasn't he wasn't that person his face
very
touching but it's still not right you
know
absolutely in your mind
what makes that that flip for eddie
where he goes from the guy who's gonna
run away to the guy who's gonna make
that final stand i think it's kind of
like towards the end of episode seven
or kind of at the beginning of episode
eight where they're kind of planning to
go to the war zone um but there is there
is literally a scene where they're kind
of getting ready and kind of preparing
for the battle where eddie has this
scene with dustin that says there will
be no more running for any spanish
um so i think kind of
um
around about then i think he kind of
decides to kind of try and
try and gather himself were there any
other scenes as a fan that you were like
because there's a lot in those last that
last episode that the fans are going to
really be drawn to was there anything
that you personally as a fan were like
yes this is a moment aside from your
your characters oh i love the bit when
that just shoots the [ __ ] out of
background that bit i don't know if i
can swear but yeah that bit where
the shotgun slo-mo moment is kind of
pretty i remember thinking that was
great
and joe's got a great monologue with
matt as well um where he's kind of
talking about
banging his head as an infant i just
anything that i find joe's stuff so
funny
there's a great line that millie has
where she says um i piggybacked here
from a pizza dough
i piggybacked from a pizza dough freezer
what
from a pizza dough refrigerator or
something like that which i think is so
good i think there's so many brilliant
moments that are just
i think
finn's monologue to millie
it's just devastating
when when she's kind of you know in a
tight spot and it's kind of him telling
her how much he loves her and he loves
her on her good days and bad days and
harper and joyce
hopper enjoys that i think that moment
where they're getting kind of undressed
and they're kind of it's they're almost
like kind of teenagers again i think
murray with the flamethrower
[Music]
i mean we're kind of spoiled i think
it's just one moment after another i'm
so
you know
and i think it's an astonishing
achievement for the duff brothers to
kind of to to tie
all of these
stories together in this kind of
this
feature-length
uh kind of episode it's just
it's it's um yeah
what what what an achievement it's kind
of i don't know it's amazing i'm sure
when you at the beginning of any
creative endeavor you never really know
which way it's going to go but then to
get that reaction from people as you
said must be staggering well it's
incredibly gratifying you know it's
we've been sat on this but for um
for many years you know it was kind of
my pandemic at the beginning of the kind
of stranger things journey as it were i
went out did my first day we went into
lockdown there was a kind of six month
hiatus and then kind of we we got to
work and
i mean the show
this season the scale of it is
enormous and the ambition is kind of
ridiculous so there was no way that it
couldn't be this kind of
pretty truncated and kind of mammoth
uh process
and you know we just everyone worked so
hard on it you know and it was kind of
because of the kind of clothing
regulations that made everything kind of
even harder but the fact that it's kind
of we put it out there and it's been so
well received and obviously personally
like the character
um i played for people to kind of be so
welcoming it's kind of um it feels like
a big exhale
yeah well done man well done and
sad we won't be seeing you in the next
season right hey you know you know let's
do this yes it's a it's a shame but um
to have been in it at all is a
remarkable privilege
[Music]
you